as coronavirus hospitalizations continue
to climb in nevada those on the front
lines are
bracing for the worst and they have a
message for all of us
thank you for joining us at 11 i'm brian
loftis and i'm denise valdez doctors
and nurses are now seeing the largest
number of cobit 19 patients
since the start of the pandemic oracle
mana joining us now live with more on
their concerns tonight orco
denise and brian the data shows an
alarming trend copen 19
hospitalizations in nevada have been
rising for the past couple of months
and the seven day moving average seen
here by these pointed arrows
clearly increasing as well health care
workers say
they're feeling the pressure we're
really doing the best we can
it's a fierce fight on the front lines
as healthcare workers continue their
battle against the coronavirus the
latest numbers from the nevada hospital
association show there are just under
1200 confirmed covet 19
hospitalization statewide some of them
are extremely sick
dr mark jesser who heads up the
summerlin hospital er
is seeing this firsthand as a few months
ago we had almost no in
covert patients in the icu and now we
have multiple dr jesser says doctors and
nurses are starting to get overwhelmed
so they're leaning on one another
we all have each other's back we when
somebody is down we help pick them up
when somebody
is depressed we talk to them and with
flu season and holiday gatherings added
to the mix there's concern about the
capacity of nevada's health care system
i expect to be busy every day we foresee
it being a bumpy winter
the cdc officially recommends americans
should not travel for thanksgiving one
worry is that asymptomatic people coming
back to vegas
could infect our most vulnerable further
filling hospitals
at this time we need to think of our
elderly population and those with
comorbid conditions who are particularly
at risk
of the severe complications of coca-19
while there are challenges ahead dr
jesser says he's prepared
this is our forte we are here to help
people we are here to save lives
now the health care workers i spoke to
say they have adequate ppe right now so
that's some good news
they're also encouraging nevadans to
continue practicing the basics
mask wearing hand washing and social
distancing
reporting live in las vegas tonight work
omana 8 news now